応援色
これが
メリケンサックだ
はぁっ
こんにちはドクター
始めようやく私ドクターはじめらしい素晴らしい実験が追いついたぞ今日実機に使う
道具がこちら右のなたこんなことを言っている者がいるぞ最強コア例題ハンガー
もうこれは言い逃れできると私は見てしまったと最強そして壊れないこの技も10回旅
のバーチャル家困難な
食われない
だけどこの法がわかりますでしょうかこの壊れないんだっていろんな色があったら3色
買ってきたぞ
もうどれにも最強を壊れない3期を壊れないって書いてるどんな月8以降の版が最強
壊れない泳いこの私ドクター初めにケンカを挑んでいるのかというわけで壊れないと
聞いたら壊したくなる男
ええええええ
それで昔失敗しているからだか私はこうはれないと聞いたら
壊したくないと言うで今日はこの最強のフォレないハンガーをぶっ壊していこうと思う
だが待って私はかつてゴルフクラブを破壊し塩蔵したことがある
私は可能な限りは塩蔵したくないので
ヘア捨てるぞ今回は壊れないって聞いたら工房壊したくなっちゃうんでさっきにこの感
がおつくった本社に連絡いたしまして破壊許可をいただきましたありがとうございます
これでこれでお前らもうこれで本当にあのこれで演奏しないんですよ
いいですもうこれだって誰もがなきゃね作った会社がいいですよって言って僕やってる
んでもう色青渡はいくつもの宴
象経験して進化し続けているのだよ作った人に許可を取れば
壊せいいです
そうとも限りませんが5ケースバイケースなんですが今回は実験の意味を込めてこう
最強に壊れない判断どれだけ復興をかけたら壊れるのが検証していきたいと思いますよ
if
たいと夕食準備がちょっとだぞお前等前からここに体協の壊れない版画をかけてまぁ
結局へしようよと間違えるとダメなのでアップま
デスクとかほどをかけるというアクションでどこまで耐えれるか実験していきたいと
思いますこれでほんと見た目がすごいんですよもう普通のハンガーと覚えないこの太さ
やこれ多分相当 dart 脛脛ここでも倒すと高
うって持ち運びも便利本人たっぷり重ねかさてこれどんな使い道があるかというと
サーフィンとが泳いだりした人の水着ってビザじゃないですか濡れた服をひっかけても
大丈夫でって言うぞ胸ハンガーらしいです私てどこがだけど悔いてあげるのかなぁ
じゃあさっそくかけていこうと思います1枚目
まだまだハンガーは壊れません2爪と爪てるっちゃ組だな
はいまだまだハンガーは壊れませんねこれでこれがヤバいけどね国家ショットずと木質
次は
なんていうんだっけこれとほっとバザーかじゃなければされた
インナーマッスルじゃなくてなんだっけまぢはされた
ヒートテック次はこちらのヒートテックです33目ですこれでキュリズシっと重くなる
けども困難で壊れて同じとたまりますよ
はいまだまだハンガーは壊れませんこれでこれだったら怒るちょっとけどまたヒート
テックつけていきましょう
ダブルヒートテックってたら思い浮かんでの直メでサイバーまだまだ困難では壊れる
わけが
ありませんと結構膨らんできましたよこれけっこうハンガーってね思って弱くてこれ
ぐらいかかると結構口に合ってない奴も多いんですよもうちょっとかけていきましょう
5作目ですよくありそうな服よくありそうな不幸後叫びに選んでいく
二期生にのってめんどくさいんですね福田さんも大変ですはい5足目つけました
まだまだ壊れます sunya ながらが多いと思います6高めいきましょう
うさ子普通の福島酸っぱい減ったらもうちょっと行ったら羽織るゲーに行きたいので
もうちょっと頑張りますっ ok 6時に切れましたあーもうてでも手でも重いレベル
だけど全然余裕6着がも問題なく入りませんじゃあそろそろちょっとずつ羽織る計を
つけていきましょう
7着目で30いただけなんだよ数字をされなぜコーディネート動画で言ってますけど
無事感じてました
8着目です普通に流し服晒せみたいな恥ずかしいんだこれも最強の般若の実力を食べた
メシャン会社内初と去年も全然大丈夫ですいやもうだいぶ多いってこれもう1 k 人気
のぐらいな気がしてるんだから守りましたけどや続いて q
先に行きましょうこれは私が知るのが恥ずかしくて買ったものどうか誰がきれなかった
プラモールのファッションショーザンもこれもまだどう声で弾く重ねる欠かせねーか
そこの戦いなってきてマナーでも大丈夫そうですねアイドル級ちゃけ名もむずいてれ
ました
いやーこれね多分で普通のハンガーだと結構やばいと思うついに折れてるよ多分って
ずっと避けてきます誰だけどぶっ壊せ
いうのがはい味全然余裕中もいけるか常に無限雪あるとかやばいぞ
ではず1着目で11着目は思いやと入れませんっていただいたぞお話していき様に
耐えれるかどうかというところだな
あ
ああああ全然呼びならねすごいようわ横暴はってもうもうやばい坊やが普通に9つと
あってこの手が痛いレベルですもう嫌
会えたことを言ってればいいからね私の目標が
壊すことほとんど行きますからねでは12着目です全然良い傾向で真贋なってなく入っ
てる
頭ピントが合い全然目関税ですねまだいけるな
では13着目いきますちょっとガラが悪いです鍋髪切れぞラーツー3枚も服重ね着する
ことないですから
はい全然大丈夫ですすごいはーやーあって多い重すぎてを過ぎてスゴいもうここまでき
たらちょっと行きましょ14着までそんなああっ
あこうやってばキッズからきっとばきったバケツたバケットはバケツったよね
何がなになになになになになにのば機なんかば切ったけどまだ何かいけそうですねー
多分
たぶん大丈夫です次は15着目ですもうね by 8機で住んででかい力行住民じゃ
ないといけないっていうねもう絶対タイミングおかしいんですけどセーターキスってみ
ましょうセーターなんか伸びるイメージがあるんで描いた大丈夫なきゃだサーんだなぁ
と切れますねまぁこれぞてょ
もうもやばいようわぁ山へ何キロだこれ
天前もうだから重すぎて書けないも立つし
バッターシースター ns も重すぎてハンガーにかけるのが一苦労な具
う
すごいなクルーとこまできたぞただまず壊れてない壊してここまで来ると壊してこの
サイズになるとね
着れる服がほぼないんですよこうなんだかオーバーサイズの服でかわしていきたいもん
だりすごいよ無限なの
混ぜてこいよ
あれ俺て何かあっあってみてくらいハーフガスが曲がってる普通はこうなんかちょっと
キレイの横なのにもうすごい周りから製造これ大丈夫か
これもずああ
そういうことがこれ多分あったじゃないすかずっとやってすぐ青森が掛かって掛かって
掛かってヤバそうになると
そうすべきストッパーが外れて行
収納される仕組みになっているみたいで相当の服がかかってたんでめちゃくちゃ重かっ
たと思うんですけどもよくあそこまでたいだと思います
こういう子はからすると炎上するんだろうな愛というとこれが普通の使い方をしていて
は絶対壊れませんなぜならこうはねそうになったら
うん閉じるんですでも逆にこの増大の耐久度を調べてみましょう
ここの強さは十分分かったんで頭ハンガーとしても大事なつい下げ後からどんだけ
釣れるかっていうちょっと試したいと思いますお福つっても誰もぎゃんテナ
がわかったので僕自身が実際にぶら下がってみると思いますではこの子時代のハンガー
としての吊り上げ力を私自身の体を使って絶景していると思う
いただきます
すーっ
まあ
それは見たらまずだっすごい商品だと思った
わー
re
me
car
uh
マッハなおれたたバカな俺だこれからかなみですねことが負ければまた使えると思うん
ですけどヒットアプリにしろ相当の数の服はかけることができるということが分かり
ました
古龍堂が取れるのねもう仏教かでね壊すと怒られるんで曲が入っただけで本当に素敵な
会社だなって思いましたありがとうございました
花をれたな